[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build Wealth live a life
worth living do work that they love have
great relationships all of it 8825 5225
it's 8 825 5225 we're taking real calls
from real people who are going through
all kinds of challenges in their life
and we're going to help you out our
promise is to sit with you and walk
alongside you as we figure out what's
the next right steple 8825 5225 I'm John
deloney joined here by Jade warshaw and
we're taking your calls on just about
anything and everything let's run out to
Salt Lake City and talk to the great and
wonderful Stacy what's up Stacy hi
what's up H nothing much just hanging
out here with my son what's up with you
we are just hanging out together too how
can we
help um I am calling because I um my
husband and I can't afford child care
and we're not succeeding financially
we're really struggling and I'm just
trying to figure out what better we can
do than what we're already doing W how
many kids do you have um one he was a
surprise and he's at weeks old eight
weeks wow you guys are in the the thick
of it cool um yes so what's the solution
now are you just staying
home um I'm on maternity leave I'm
supposed to be going back to work in
about four weeks um I was full-time I'm
still technically full-time but I'm the
hope is to go back part-time um but it's
it's retail so it's in person so I'm
looking for something I could do
remotely Ely so I could stay home with
him okay and then my husband works in an
office so is the issue that you're
having a hard time finding the part-time
job that you want to make this work or
is the problem that you're having a hard
time finding a dayare price that would
work in any
case I'm I'm looking I'm having a hard
time finding remote work um I'm hoping
to work remotely full-time um and also I
just um my husband knew I brought some a
lot of debt into the marriage um and um
we were working at paying it off how
much is it surprised us um between car
personal and um and credit cards and um
a school probably between 30 and
40,000 okay um we're working on the
credit cards first I just dealt with a
lot of mental health struggles growing
um you know in my
young adult years and
so um I and also I just grew up poor so
I try to learn on my own how to how to
do it all and I didn't fully succeed so
45,000 between those that you listed 30
and 40 between 30 and 40 okay and does
your husband have any debt or he's not
bringing any into the relationship he
didn't bring any other than um his truck
but his parents are currently paying
that and how much is that I I'm not sure
just because um uh just because it's not
one of my current bills but it was a
used truck and so I'm pretty sure it's
like you know between 10 and
15,000 okay and yeah 15,000 at the most
if you had to guess I'm sorry I'm just
getting the particulars so I get a lay
of the land no you're good um if you had
to guess between the two of you because
it sounds like you're not fully combined
on your finances it sounds like you kind
of have a separate thing going on but if
you had to guess uh what do you both
make combined uh before you before you
make these career changes what was it
before um we we were making about 4,000
a month total like we work together but
we do have separate accounts at the
moment um just because we never we never
did combine them but we work together on
paying stuff so I know we make about
4,000 he pays rent um and I pay pretty
much everything else so let me clarify
because a lot of people do this thing
where it's like I make my money you make
your money and then we throw some of our
money into this joint pile that pays all
the bills but there's also other money
in my personal account that 4,000 is
that all the money combined or is that
just money what does he do for a living
okay he um ironically he works in
finance he's a de
collector so he doesn't make enough
money um no he doesn't make enough money
um he
um he just started like his career and
stuff Co he just ended that career
because he's got to go make more
money yeah yeah I know sometimes makes
bonuses and stuff but could care less
about that it's not
enough yeah and I don't know that you
can go to not working or even working
part-time I think whatever you do you're
going to need to work full-time until
he's able to make that spread as well
his mommy still paying his truck payment
could she wash your kid a few hours a
day
no we're in different
states okay and um yeah we're we're in
different states and uh I'm planning on
working remotely fulltime as soon as I
can find something it's just a matter of
finding something okay and I'm just like
running out of time and we're how hard
are you looking are you sending out 15
20 applications a day probably not that
many a day probably three or four a day
just because um you know taking care of
my son and stuff but I'm applying as
many as I can okay and I'm reaching out
to people and stuff like that if in four
weeks when your uh leave is over if you
haven't found that full-time remote job
what do you think the plan of action
would be in your mind what's the course
of action at that point I'm hoping
that's not the case but if you find
yourself in that situation what would
you
do uh at that point I'll work evenings
and weekends at my um current job and
probably do door Dash during the day
with my son and would that be enough to
cover the
daycare um we like we aren't comfortable
doing daycare and like um I I want him
with me and so whatever at work I want
to do is something I could do with him
like that's why I'm looking for remote
work here's the deal you may have
answered this question several years ago
with some of your financial
choices and I know this is hard to hear
but you owe
$45,000 and so what you want to not to
mention whatever your husband owes more
like 35 yeah whatever it is and here's
the problem a you don't fully know what
that number is and you don't know what
his number is you don't know what
exactly the amount of money you make is
because you don't know if he has a
separate account or if his momm is
sending him money to help with the you
don't
know I have access to his account full
access to his account like to the one he
gives you Jade and I wouldn't have jobs
if husbands and wives told each other
the truth all the time about money
that's right and so this isn't a math
problem this is a wife who is living the
the life of a single mom inside of her
own
house and y'all have to get
together and he has to recognize he's
got to go make a whole bunch more money
and he just started a career that career
does not provide for his family at this
moment and you want to stay home with
this baby you may have to work for a
season to get that 35 Grand knocked out
so that you can afford to stay home with
this
baby yeah and I know that's scary I know
that's hard but we love you too much to
not tell you the truth that's
right you have a lot more years ahead of
you with that baby it's and it's easy to
forget and and think that it's just
right now but you've got years and years
to stay at home with that kid you got a
big big hole the all of this starts with
you sitting down with your husband and
saying I'm so scared I can't breathe we
have to put everything on the table and
tell the
[Music]
truth hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a 5,000 ,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
this is the ramsy showle 8825 5225 I'm
John deloney joined by Jade warshaw Jade
what did you do I didn't do anything you
did you super did look I posted a video
on Facebook specifically about how like
zero credit scores work and these folks
came for my life John dude they were
showering you with the hater Aid so I
was thinking you know what I usually
stay out of the comments or I'm like
pretty you know just nonchalant about it
but these these comments were extra and
I was like you know what I need to I
need to I need to clap back on this so
let's play the video so you guys can
just see how innocent what I said was
and you can be on my side and then we'll
chop it up all right let's do it it
usually takes about a year to see your
credit score go down to absolute zero if
you completely stop borrowing money and
here's the thing if you dilly dally with
this and you're like I'm going to keep
that one credit card open it's never
going to go to zero you're just going to
have a bad credit score and then when
you try to go buy a house you're going
to run into problems look yeah I stand
by that I stand by that message I
approve that message all right I'm going
to read some of the haterade all right
read it Chad says these people are crazy
zero credit score is not even possible
okay uh Tim says this is absolutely not
correct you need to raise your credit
score not lower it this explains so much
about some
people Derek says this kind of crap's
annoying while it's possible to buy a
house without a credit score it isn't
worth the Hoops okay better off with a
credit scored the next one's my favorite
yeah Jacob says says the woman with tons
of assets to lean on and has no need for
I can't I can't I'm coming out of my I'm
coming out of my seat right now because
and I did reply to that when I was like
oh you must not know me or my story if
you think I came from wealth and assets
are you kidding me I got to throw my pin
across the room because hold on hold on
this this cat says I swear the ramsy
team's advice on credited is the
stupidest be beep ever good luck getting
approved for Jack be beep with no credit
that's the whole point here's my my
thing here's my thing John and this is
crazy to me people would rather be
right about what they think and about
what they know then be free then be
happy then be better off in life they
they'd rather be right about the fact
that there's no other way to get ahead
in society than to be strapped with debt
for eternity yes like you have to play
the debt game that's the only it's the
only way to Make It in America is to
have a credit score are you kidding me
you'd rather be right about that and I'm
like really you want to be right about
something that keeps you in slavery your
entire life forever it's that important
to you and dude for all of human history
this is how governments capture their
citizens right by giving them a plot of
land and saying when it's paid off then
it's all yours free and the next year
it's like oh well we had to raise the
price on it so uh and they do that in
perpetuity and now we wear this score
like we win something and I'm the only
one the folks in this room are some of
the only ones in the United States World
telling y'all hey there's a better way
and we we try to do it with love we try
to tell y'all hey there's a better way
we want you to be free we want to help
you we exist to help the people outside
of these walls and it's crazy that
people clap back on me like I'm trying
to hurt them and they're not clapping
back at the credit collectors they're
not clapping back at FICO or Experian or
TransUnion they're yelling at me when
I'm the one I'm the one going hey
there's a way that you don't have to
play this stupid game you don't have to
Rack your family with debt you don't
have to you know rob Peter to pay Paul
and move this money over here and keep
your credit around for x amount of years
with x amount of varieties of credit
with x amount of percentage used like
that is a game and the goalpost is
constantly moving and one of the things
I noticed that they were mad at me as I
said hey if you're going to run our plan
like run it to the end zone like do it
all the way don't do this mess of well
I'm going to pay off my credit but I'm
going to keep a couple of cards open or
keep that one card open just in case cuz
that'll jack your credit even worse
right because there are ways that
they're measuring your credit it's not
just hey have one credit card open you
have to utilize that credit and you have
to keep it around for a long time and
you have to make sure the percentage is
Right otherwise yeah you'll have a score
but it won't be great it'll probably be
pretty bad and the fact is having a
I'mma say it and I'm going scream it
till the cows come home having a zero
credit score is just as good in my
opinion better than having a 750 or a
800 because I don't have to play the
game of debt I get to be my own woman my
own man my husband and we're autonomous
and we are free and we don't have to be
slaves to the system so if you don't
like that you can go ahead and put that
Yol back on and they can yeah and you'll
just pull the plow of debt for them and
you can do that the rest of your life
I'm not going as for me in my house
making other people Rich at your expense
look hey I I can we run through this
real quick yeah these people are crazy
zero credit score is not even possible
your false false it's false once you pay
off your debt like I said it takes about
and you close the accounts you've got to
close them it takes about 6 to 12 months
for your credit score to roll to zero
that's how it goes this is absolutely
not correct you need to raise your
credit score not lower it why false why
yeah you tell me why so that one day you
can go get on both knees and hold your
hands up and say dear lender please
please and they'll say well let me let
me look in my secret file and see what
your score is yeah instead of sitting
down with your wife and when your air
conditioner goes out and you have become
your own bank over 15 years which is
what took me and my wife and your
argument is not please please can I it's
you call I'm not calling you call I
don't want to call you call I love it
that's that's the most annoying fight
you have yeah right and I think people
forget the fact that when you decide
John like Hey we're going to pay off our
debt that simultaneously means and we're
not going back into debt and we're not
doing this thing called credit anymore
and the biggest argument is yeah but if
you don't have a credit score how are
you going to live and the biggest two
areas that people are thinking about are
cars and living situation right can you
buy a car without credit yes you can
it's called buying a car in cash and I'm
not talking about that you always have
to save $40,000 or $50,000 to buy the
newest model the cars that Sam warshaw
and Jade warshaw Drive are from 2013
and I think we paid less than I don't
know 20,000 for both yeah each of them
that's how you do this you don't have
and don't get me wrong I could have way
more car than that John at this point in
my life I just don't care about it that
much so don't tell me it's not possible
you save up your money and it takes time
uh let me just say this my husband and I
for the first time in our marriage are a
two-car family and that happened last
year because that's just the life we
chose we didn't have to do that for that
long but we said you know what I don't
care about going into debt over cars and
when we feel like paying up cash and
buying a second car we will and that's
what you're talking about you just
choose it was in it was up until this
this year I I went from a 96 to a 2012
and I was driving 2012 forever yeah and
Dave just just Dave as my friend goes
hey I know what I pay you what are you
doing and I was like he's like you're
trying to like make a point I go I I I
honestly don't care don't care and it
was only that I was like I'm going to
get and by the way I went all in on a
Highlander it's not like you know what I
mean and dude every day I get in it I
smile so big like like I've beat
somebody like like I've won some game
and my buddies are like it's it's not
it's not a cool car John come on I know
but it's like I know but it it doesn't
have a CD player in it anymore right
here's the deal when you unhook yourself
from the external expectation yeah my
wife likes me and you know how I know
she likes me because she was dating me
when I was driving an 88 T easy
hatchback let's go so I know this is
love right and that when we were making
it when we were when we when Dave was
paying us more money than any Delon had
ever wrapped their head
around I I didn't need to prove anything
to anybody no it's not a game right it's
like yeah I was able to Cobble together
the money and pay for that in cash and
it's just it's mine the money saying
what you buy it doesn't determine your
worth hey uh one more thing um what
about housing let me hit this right
quick people think you can't buy a house
with a zero credit score yes you can
it's called manual underwriting I did it
John deloney did it George camell did it
I know Rachel Cruz did it all these
folks did it all you need is payment
history 12 months showing your trade
lines cell phone bills utilities you
need actual money you need to show 12
months of bank statements and just your
last 30 days but that's so many Hoops
it's not almost the same as the normal
process it's not hey by the way Church
Hill mortgage is a place to go guys yes
and man if you just weren't so rich uh
you wouldn't be able to talk like this
[Music]
Jade hey folks Dr John delone here with
some great news new you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become Healthy
Habits Like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
and meditation one thing that has helped
me with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember halow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramy today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
this is the ramsy showle 8825 5225 I'm
John delone joined by Jade warshaw let's
go out to Destin Florida and talk to
Josh what's up brother Josh hey how you
doing good man how are you I'm okay I
appreciate you taking the call you got
it man what's
up oh I guess I'll cut right to it um
so I've been following you guys for a
little while trying to get my finances
on
track but I've come to a decision I need
to start handling my life and get some
stuff on track and I want to go to rehab
so I can uh quit my drinking dude I'm
proud of you man I'm hold on hold on
hold on Don't Blow by that that's huge
what led you
here um there are millions and millions
of people in the United States that need
to make this decision and I want them to
hear where you
landed you'll be a gift I
mean in the past I battled with uh other
substance abuse issues and I let that go
been clean from all that and I just kind
of picked up the
bottle and just tired of it tired of
doing the same things over and over
again tired of relying on something to
feel like I need it to function awesome
I'm proud of you man I'm proud of you so
uh how can we
help well pretty much my insurance
situation the only way to get into
treatment uh it covers most of it except
for about $6,000 okay6 to $10,000
depending on
location
so really not trying to get into any
more debt sure but I want to take care
of this
um the first question I would ask
is um
often and I'm talking about rehab places
that are not like go to Malibu or you're
in Destin not like a beachfront place
that's going to be a resort okay um yeah
often if you sit down places will wave
the gap between the insurance and the
the what the cash out okay it's it's a
it's the equivalent of a scholarship
program so I would have that
conversation with the place have you
done that I've been calling and asking
for scholarships I've called
hundreds of places probably you haven't
called hundreds slight exaggeration but
yeah a lot a big exaggeration but and
nobody will wave the Gap no not that'll
cover my
insurance what do you mean because
that's the that's the cheap the cheapest
thing I've been able to find is a $6,000
copay oh is that your deductible yes
that's the cheapest thing I can get I've
applied for scholarships they're saying
they're not doing it so do you have guns
or guitar or a truck you have something
you can
sell no I mean I've got a truck but it's
my work
truck can you go down and value on it
what's it worth no I'm upside down in it
what's it
worth uh probably about 11 Grand what do
you about 200,000 miles on it
12 what what would happen you owe 12
it's worth 11
what would happen if you sold that and
went down half the value and just bought
yourself a little truck that that'll get
you is there anything do you see what
I'm saying like this is temporary I get
what you I get what you're saying but
it's a truck with 200,000 miles on it
and not that many people are going to
spend $11,000 well if it's worth 11,000
there's a whole bunch of people will my
friend CU they're in your situation too
what about a parent or family member NOP
unfortunately no Okay so here's what I
would tell you I would start if I'm you
in this
situation I would start with a couple of
different uh areas number one I would
walk in this
evening to the local AA meeting have you
done that yet yeah okay I would ask
around and tell them I've got a
gap and my guess is there's people who
would say I I know X Y and Z I know this
person my church has a sponsorship
program there's a there's there's Gap
payment here we can help figure this out
I would start
there okay okay and this is you being
super super vulnerable it sounds like
you're so sick of all this that you're
kind of done giving a crap is that
fair absolutely okay the second thing is
I'm going to give you three months of
free better help I want you to talk to a
licensed counselor I want you to hang on
the line here and I want you to make
sure that just full stop rehab is the
right move the right next move for
you okay okay they might say hey I want
you to go every day to a meeting in the
evening and in the morning for 30 days
and let's Circle back before we make
this list this entire this big leap
Okay Okay the third thing is I want you
to be
honest deeply honest with what you can
part with right now because here's what
I'm trying to avoid I don't want you to
come out on the other side of a 30-day
intreatment program or a 28 day um um
outpatient
program and have that Clarity of mind
that
sobriety the light is on and then that
credit card bill hit you right in the
mouth that's what I want to avoid at all
cost and that's another thing I'm
worried about finances bills keep coming
they do keep coming even been looking
into detoxes and it's still about that
same number just for like a week detox
they do I want you to go to a meeting
and I want you to be vulnerable and
raise your hand and say I'm
stuck okay y if you tell me after 30
days of knocking on every door put your
car on Facebook Marketplace and see if
you can get $6,000 for it or 7,000 or
11,000 bucks that's going to give you
six grand and you go buy a $55,000 car
with 250,000 m truck I get it not pretty
this is a Band-Aid I get it if you tell
me you can't then I I would say then go
to a local um uh a local uh Credit Union
and figure out that Gap or I would work
out before you did that I would see if
you could work out a payment plan with
the rehab place probably they won't do
that but it'd be worth a shot oh no no
they will they will do that that's why I
was no interest but that's why I was
call I've already got other debt backed
up okay I'm okay with that one if the
last option and listen to me this is not
a pass for you just to go sweet I can go
I want you to exhaust every Avenue
because my brother Jade and I have sat
with people they walk
out and then reality is a cold dose of
water and it's easy to fall right back
into Old Habits when old um fists hit
you in the same mouth yeah cuz even if
you can find a couple of thousand like
even if you can find a couple of
thousand from selling things you visit a
local church and say hey is there any
like is there a ministry here what what
can I do can I serve to earn this money
like whatever you can figure out even if
you're closing that Gap with cash in
some in some way that's going to be
worth it too or if you got two weeks and
you decide I'm going to wake up at 5:00
every morning and drive Uber and I am
going
to um I'm going to I'm going to work
like mad and earn this money right
there's going to be some little
victories there but if you tell me hey
man I I can't I'm underwater right now
I'm want to go to rehab because I'm
drinking every day and I can't stay
clean I get that and I honor that okay
but I want you to go to a meeting
tonight and I want you to raise your
hand and ask that question okay okay if
you can if the hospital where you are
doing your um impatient rehab is willing
to say there's an interest free option
here for the Gap then I'm okay with that
as a last Defcon Resort option if a
clinical Supervisor has said your only
option is
rehab okay okay so I want you to hang on
the line I want you to walk through I
want you to when you go through the
better help I want you to click on
struggling with substance abuse
struggling with alcohol and I want you
to put in the notes trying to make a
decision on whether I need to go to
rehab go to impatient impatient rehab C
counseling and then when they reach out
they're going to walk you through an
assessment and y'all can make that
decision together is that cool yeah
that's awesome thank you so much I I
appreciate everything you got hey I need
you to hear I need you to hear me say
I'm really proud of you me too thank you
this is real hard you've been you've
been um drowning for a long time haven't
you yeah yeah we're
done okay are we
done with all the drinking yes I I want
to be I mean I'm tired of it good hey U
I'm going to put a little star on this I
want you to call back in 30 days with
your 30-day chip and um we're going to
celebrate you on the air all right I'm
proud of you my man this is the Ramy
show we'll be right
[Music]
back well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netsuite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us net week
worked for Ramy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramy
triple
8825 5225 this is the Ramy show hey it's
almost the holiday
season and if you are already getting
sweaty armpits thinking about
Thanksgiving with
family and
Christmas I got you I got you we've
created some new questions for humans
this year we have a Thanksgiving deck to
talk about gratitude you can sit down at
the Thanksgiving table and look around
around and say no politics nobody cares
no negative nonsense on this one no TVs
everybody put your stupid phones down
we're going to ask these questions and
it's for the whole family we also made a
new Christmas deck and with Super Rad we
made a new deck and this is because you
asked for it for grandparents and kids
it's a great way for you and your spouse
to go out to dinner and say Mom Dad you
can be with the grandkids and don't be
weird here are some cards we got you go
to ramseys solutions.com and save your
holidays love let's go out to uh Detroit
Rock City and talk to Sarah what's up
Sarah hi how are you guys today good how
are you I'm doing amazing thanks for
asking awesome what's
up I am calling because I am debating on
if I should move or if I should stay in
my current home um we currently have a
home where we owe about 13 ,000 on it we
have a great interest rate of only
2.2
5% but we have some structural issues
going on in our basement um my husband
and I yeah and it's going to be really
expensive how expensive it's G to be
maybe like around
$70,000 the person who sold us the home
was not 100% truthful about the issue
that were going on and he covered up um
some stuff that's sound like he was z%
truthful
so if you were yes he actually we're
dealing with some foundational issues
and he covered it up with cement so it
got past me my husband the inspector it
got past everyone and now we're in
Jeopardy of losing our homeowners
insurance oh if you don't get it
repaired exactly and they're giving us
like a very short window to get it
repaired what's the window has um like
three months what Dang son uh if you
were to let go of this house let's let's
pretend you did sell it uh what would
you what would it
bring in profit
15,000 15,000 H yes and how long have
you lived in this house we've only we
moved it in
2020 okay how much is would it bring
you well from the suggestions of my
realtor the house is worth based on the
area the house is worth a lot more than
what we would list it for but due to the
foundational issu the
issues yeah she's thinking that we
should list the house at
159 um but if we were
to possibly try and at least do part of
the repairs and maybe speak to the
homeowners uh insurance company and see
if maybe they can work something out
with us I'm wondering about that I'm
wondering if you and your husband sit
down and put together a plan of phases
and say hey in Phase One this is what
we're getting done and here's the the
time frame for that and then in PH phase
two starts at at X date and here's what
we're doing there and here's the the 12
Monon plan or the you know whatever
month plan for this to be completely
fixed and healed yeah did you guys did
did y'all try to report it as an
insurance loss and they came out and
went through everything and then they
tagged you for a mistake yeah that's
happened to me before too
um and when they came out we were
thinking that maybe they would cover it
and they were like no we're not going to
cover it and we're not gonna R pretty
much is what happened yeah yeah I hate
that man you can't even ask a question
anymore and they'll just burn you I want
you to um while you're doing this I
Jades is is what I would do if I'm
sitting down with my wife like if I'm
being honest trying to put skin in this
game I would sit down with my wife and
say okay we don't have $70,000 I'm
assuming you don't have 70,000 bucks in
cash oh absolutely not okay um you have
any
money um right now at the moment no
we're currently working on the baby
death we paid off all of my husband's
credit card uhhuh um and we're paying
off mine as well what do you have left
to go on the
debt um maybe like around 20 okay okay
and can I just ask you guys' combined
income
120 120 so 20,000 left in debt 120
income yeah I mean we're pausing this
right now you you think Jade I I I think
you have to if they're giving you 3
months before you lose your insurance
and be like yeah you you got to you got
to move this to the top of the list or
at the very least like I said you've got
to come up with this plan of action find
out what they're going to do now let's
let's give her option b just in case
option b is I want you to call my
friends at Xander Insurance okay and
here's what Xander is they're they're a
broker and they call a whole bunch of
different companies and get the best
rates and I want you to be honest and
talk with um the broker and say we got
some Foundation issues we called our
insurance company and then they did this
to us and let them walk you through what
the next step is if they tell you I'm
sorry this means your house is
completely uninsurable well now you know
but I bet that's not going to be the
case that is okay okay and that gives
you option two here is not option three
I don't want you going out and borrowing
$70,000 on this house that's right
okay you think you're stressed
now well you yeah you think you're
stressed now you put 70 you you go
upside down on your house on foundation
repair and you're not going to be able
to sleep or breathe okay yeah okay I
love the idea of sitting down getting
one or not not one getting two or three
different um um quotes on this and have
them do it in stages and what they're
going to want to do is come do it all at
the same time you can look at them and
smile and say I'm going to pay for cash
as I go I need you to break this up into
have to have right now right this second
what's stage two what's stage three and
on and on and on
okay okay yeah that I mean look these
are those moments where you being
brutally honest with whoever's coming to
your house and doing those estimates
they're gonna because that there's a
real person on the other side of that
right and if you say to them hey you
know like
this is going to cost $70,000 here's
what the insurance told us we cannot
afford to lose this house you know our
interest rate we can't go into another
Market where the interest rate is going
to be 7% like if you start talking like
that to a human being and you're showing
that you're a human being too A lot of
times you will be surprised at what
they're able to meet you at and if you
can have them you know kind of shift
into your shoes of like you know what
would you do and you know is there any
way because if you were in this
situation I mean it seems like you would
want to do the same thing if you can get
them thinking like that that's that's
good and by the way 70,000 bucks on a
$150,000
home what are they doing man they going
to lift your whole house and redo the
whole all the blocking underneath the
whole thing well that's yeah that's the
thing too where we've had like three
people to come out and give estimates
and 70,000 was like at the top of the
list but okay they're all three of them
are saying three different things one is
saying oh we can just waterproof it the
other one is saying oh we can put beans
up and push the wall out and then the
third one is said we have to redo the
entire wall of course let me ask you
this uh
Sarah how do you feel about it because I
I'm listening to you talk and I'm like
dude if I was in my house and they're
telling me their structural damage and
like what my house can crumble on me and
my family there is Part Of Me John
that's like get me out I don't trust any
of y'all to make sure that this is right
especially if y'all are all telling me
something different is that does that
hit a nerve at
all um it did at first
um we were actually in the process of
trying to move and list our house but
when I just looked at the numbers it
just didn't seem worth it to me as I as
Dave Ry I said I'd rather eat beans and
rice and just Thug It Out keep my
current home because I love the home
that work there you go that's what you
do it may be that you have to bite the
bullet on this one and pay to have it
waterproof so you can get it through the
insurance and yeah then you're going to
have to save up money and come put peers
in that wall and lift the house up and
level it and go with peers and that's
going to not only get you through
inspection but it's going to the whole
house is going to be structurally sound
right and yes it would be cool if I
could do a complete frame off
restoration of my truck I can't afford
to do that but I can replace the shocks
right and it's going to drive great and
it's going to be safe and so it might be
finding some Middle Ground over time but
call our friends at Xander and get some
updates on the insurance cuz you may
want to tell your insurance company you
know what I fire you I fire you hey this
the first hour in the books we'll be
right back on the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build we wealth get out of
Deb do work that they love and create
incredible relationships and speak
clearly we help with that too I'm John
deloney joined here by my friend Jade
warshaw and we have um the lines open
8825 5225 that's
5225 let's run out to New Hampshire and
talk to Dylan what's up Dylan how we
doing hey I uh just had a quick question
for you both uh I'm assuming John you'll
be able to answer this a little better
but you might J is way smarter than me
well well we'll see how it goes um so it
would seem that my mom is boycotting my
rehearsal and my rehearsal dinner
because I changed uh a small
plan I don't know I might be able to
answer this one because I know about
that dude I'm I'm laughing with you man
like so what what' you do Richard what
you what did you change that was so bad
so I'll run it quick so um you know back
months ago when we gave them the
opportunity to uh kind of plan the
dinner it's not what we wanted
originally we told them you know we just
wanted to have pizza and go back to the
Airbnb and just have a good time with
the bridal party but my mom absolutely
insisted on um paying for this and
making you know a big dinner we go out
and all this and that obviously you know
listening to you guys like trying to
save as much money as possible but uh
she wasn't on board with that um and you
know I gave her the opportunity for
months and months and months and a few
days ago I talked to her and told her
I'm like Hey we're really thinking about
switching back to our original plan and
I was like I'll give you a few days to
uh figure it out well I just waited one
day and I was like you know what I
should do what I really want to do it's
my special day you know and my of course
my fiance too but um and I decided I'm
like hey this is what we're going to do
instead um you know I
I didn't see this coming but I want to
lean on you a little bit and you push
back okay of course why would you take
this from your mom it's like a dinner
that she's paying
for be well just because it's originally
not what we wanted and she I should add
to this too she started inviting a bunch
of people that we didn't want there
there it is go okay that too lead with
that brother lead lead with that because
that that changed game but that was that
wasn't the biggest issue I don't think
is that she didn't really respect that
we originally wanted to do something
else that's how I took it Dylan is there
strings attached to this as in as in I'm
doing this for you so somewhere down the
line there's going to be an expectation
of something I want from
you you know there I'm not going to go
as far as that but it's not possibility
oh I know I know about
it um all right so here's here's the
deal this is as as heartbreaking and
complicated as this is this is very very
simple you made a grown-up
choice and with all grown-up choices
there always comes grown-up consequences
to those
choices
unfortunately your mom is choosing to
act like a child and I mean that with
all due respect I don't like talking
about people's masas but here we are oh
I've said it a few times right so one of
the hardest things
I think any of us will experience is
when somebody we love opts out of
relationship with us because they're
choosing to be immature because they are
making our whatever how we're raising
our kid what school our kid goes to our
choice of diet our whatever you want to
say they make our lives about them yeah
and she is choosing to not be in
relationship with you and your wife
during your big day
day and that just hurts and so it's a
both end I want you to spend time even
just for a few minutes saying like this
sucks man I want my mom in my wedding I
hate that she's acting like this and you
and I both know she acts like this on
other things too this isn't isolated
right no not at all awesome and can I
add something of course she's gonna come
to your
dinner well I think she hoping I'm
hoping so I would write her a letter so
bad here I would write her a letter that
she can go back to over and over and
over
again and say we really it would mean
the world to us that you come I know
that you you wanted a big a big thing
and I'm so grateful that you're honoring
us to this one we really want you here
yeah I mean the thing is that uh I mean
she won't even come to the rehearsal
which I which is the worst part to me
I'm okay if she didn't want to come to
the dinner she's saying that she's
saying that and I don't know her so I
may be totally off base I think that
this is her lastage effort to get her
away on this and my I would probably be
willing to
put couple I put some chips on the table
on this that she's going to end up there
I don't think she's going to miss her
son's major days over this now maybe I
don't know her and and I'm come
completely wrong but uh something tells
me that when the rubber hits the road
she's going to be there what about your
old man have you talked to him about it
yeah I actually spoke to him today and
he just initially you know his first
time also keep in mind my my mother
won't to me at all she will not talk to
me of course well you ruined her life
jerk oh you know yeah absolutely ripping
her heart out but I did speak to my dad
this morning and he was saying that she
just feels hurt and that it doesn't have
anything to do with the dinner which I
don't believe because this kind of stuff
has happened before which she doesn't
get her way in this which I don't
believe but uh well he's probably been
covering her for her for a long time too
right oh of course yeah I mean obviously
he has to take her side in most cases
and I don't blame him but yeah no I mean
yeah no I spoke to him and will talk to
you the best the best I can tell you is
what I would do in your situation and
that would be I would write a letter and
I would do my best to deliver it by hand
if you all in the same if you all live
in the same Community put it in her
mailbox by hand I was at her house
yesterday okay and let her have
something cuz listen if you call her if
you text her she is going to hear that
one time in her through her filter of
Dylan is trying to ruin my life yeah and
Dylan's going to embarrass me because
I'm in charge of the dinner and
everyone's going to ask me why I just
did pizza and it's all about her but if
you write it down people can go back to
the letter and back to it and back to it
and sometimes not always but sometimes
that truth has a way of distilling
itself down and she can rest in he wants
me there him and his wife are just
trying to do things a little bit
differently it's not about me Etc and
you hope that's the case but we all have
what I'm hoping but a great idea truth
and tell your dad we really really want
both of y'all there oh I I told him that
I told him that this morning when I
spoke to him like if the worst case
scenario happens I'm like please dad be
at my wedding yes like at the very least
like yeah yeah know it's pretty crazy I
hate it for you I hate it for you I
appreciate it thank you though but yeah
that was pretty much it I appreciate you
guys yeah I don't get to it's not every
day I get to talk to somebody who just
willy nilly rips his mom's heart out
right dude look when it comes to these
weddings it's like that like if I had
done what all the parents had wanted I
would have been married in a different
state I would have been got I would have
gotten married on a different date I
would have gotten married you know in a
different dress like they all have their
preferences but at the end of the day it
is your it's your ADV it's your day your
thing and sometimes it's just a dinner
do the dinner but if it is that big of a
deal you made a grown-up choice and that
comes with grownup consequence that's
right hey this is the Ramsey Show we'll
be right
back
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and the their team is
ready to help with everything from
design consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com
rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply this is the ramsy show what's up
we're so glad you're with usle 8825
5225 hey Jade um I'm reading this
CNN.com article says Americans ran up
1005 billion dollar in credit card
interest last year alone and about one
in 10 about 10% of general purpose
credit card accounts the United States
were in what they call persistent debt
which is this Loop you can't get out
because the interest and fees are more
than the minimum
payments yeah wow wow says um the
industry uses Rewards to get you in you
think you're going to pay everything off
every month but then some things don't
go as planned yeah that's the whole
purpose of this show people get stuck
and they get um and and it just gets in
this Loop and this is just the people in
persistent debt this does not include
the other 90% that are locked in at some
shape form or fashion become part of
their life that's right you and Rachel
Cruz have partnered up with every dollar
the greatest budgeting app in the
universe to do some trainings tell us
about them that's right so you're going
to hear us talk about this all the time
this is something that we're doing
consistently about two times a month
we're hosting webinars here at Ramsey
Solutions they're totally free and the
webinars are to teach you how to budget
cuz we hear I mean for a lot of people
budgeting is a new concept or if it's
not completely new you were doing it
before but you didn't realize you were
doing it the wrong way that's why it
wasn't working for you so we're giving
up an hour and a half of our time a
couple of times a month so that you can
get this knowledge and so that you can
break free from that paycheck to
paycheck cycle so that you can learn how
to budget and not just with app we want
you to learn how to budget with every
dollar and so not only is the webinar
free but you can download every dollar
and start using that app for free so we
want to help you guys and this is how
we're going to do all you need to do is
show up it's during your lunch break I
say it all the time you can sit and eat
your sub sandwich you can eat your Lan
Cuisine and no one's going to know that
you have broccoli in your teeth because
you're going to be on the interwebs with
us you don't have to show your face you
can just get this good knowledge and
change your life and I I just want to
talk to to the folks out there who are
rolling their eyes if I say something
like hey uh how do you lose weight and
um a friend of mine who's Dr Lane Norton
one the best nutritionist on the planet
says uh diet and exercise I can go oh
you know thanks yeah right and of course
there's so much more to it than that but
I look at someone like that like Lane
who's ripped he wins these these Awards
he's got a PhD in it and I just think to
myself I'm just going to go figure it
out right and I don't have the courage
to
say I need some help like can you walk
me through this and I he's a friend of
mine so he'll walk me through at the at
the microscop level at the big at the
macro level this is very similar it's
easy to say okay I'll make a
budget okay the reality is if people
knew how to do this we wouldn't have
this mess we got 100% right and so have
the courage to be vulnerable and say all
right I'm going to tune in I'm going to
go to every dollar
./ budgeting every.com
budgeting I'm going to sit there for an
hour and a half and I'm going to
actually get the tools on how to do this
yeah and if you don't want to talk you
don't have to talk you can let everybody
else do the talking or if you're like no
I have specific questions you can put
those questions in the chat we answer
them uh or you can come on live and you
can actually talk with us and ask your
questions so this is super interactive
and like you said this is not just us
saying yeah spend less money than you
make this is us going in and giving you
the actual recipe okay here's how you go
in and act do it these are the the macro
steps in order to get this done so and
by the way this is me just again being
vulnerable I have taken the headset off
on this very stage that I'm sitting on
right now and asked Dave a budgeting
question I've asked I've called George
and said hey man how do I I do this for
a living and I'm still getting some
coaching right and so it's there's no
shame in the game
just seek peace in your life and if you
don't have the skills go to to www.
everydollar.com
budgeting and I also understand that I
make myself look 108 years sound 108
years old when I said www you did go to
everydollar.com
budgeting sign up the seats are limited
so get up there and do it and join Jade
join Rachel for one of these budgeting
um uh trainings man get it done get it
done get it done all right the
neighborly question of the day the
question today sponsored by neighborly
your hub for Home Services when a
disaster like a fire or flood strike
strikes neighborly rainbow restoration
offers homeowners full restoration
services plus mold remediation carpet
cleaning odor removal and more download
the neighborly app now to find rainbow
restoration services near you all right
today's question comes from Manuel in
Arizona he says I'm getting married to
the love of my life I am
Mexican-American born in the US and
raised in Mexico I'm a dentist and I'm
also on track to pay off my student
loans in the next year I make about
$300,000 a year my fin my fiance is an
in IND endodon in Mexico uh when we get
married she has agreed to move to the US
with me which means she will no longer
be able to practice Dentistry uh we have
talked about this and she has agreed to
become a stay-at-home wife especially
when we have kids I make I make enough
money to be able to support a family but
I'm afraid of my wife not being able to
adjust to not making money yeah what is
the best way to handle this and allow
her to keep some individuality when it
comes to finances she has worked really
hard to become a doctor and she has made
good money in Mexico as an endodontist
the last few years it will be a big
change to have to depend on me
financially oh Lord look um I I'm going
to say something brief and then I'm
going to let John take this
away the biggest and best thing you can
do is to flip the script and put
yourself in her shoes and how would it
feel if you moved countries and let go
of a degree that you worked really hard
for and a you know a career path that
you worked very hard for that you
enjoyed doing um when I hear the words
that says she agreed to move to the US
and she agreed that she will no longer
be able to practice Dentistry there's
part of that and she has agreed to
become a stay-at-home wife there's part
of that that makes it seem like this was
your suggestion and she's like okay
they're working through a contract yeah
that go ahead John no you keep going uh
my I just as a woman there is part of
that that's like the way this sounds the
way it's worded and it might be the way
it's worded is it does sound to me like
on Down the Line she could look up and
feel resentful and feel like I gave up
everything for this and I'm not sure
that I wanted to do that and where is
your
sacrifice there you go and so I in in my
house my wife was Dr deloney before I
was yeah and then when we made a move
for my job and my me trying to get my
head screwed back on straight when I was
struggling with mental health stuff she
went to work parttime at a local school
and so she went from Dr deloney to hey
Miss in one year wow and then she went
to hey I'm going to stay at home for a
season and now she's an author and
coaches women does a bunch of their
stuff but all along the way there was
this big identity shift and there was
some big changes and I've come to find
out by just sitting with countless women
over the last decade there's no way to
win right you're not at home enough or
you're home too much or you need to be
making more money or how dare you make
money instead of there's just a guilt
industry designed to to keep women from
ever getting both feet on the ground I'm
here for that and so I think the best
the what I've learned Manuel through my
trial and error and I've made many many
mistakes along the way is I want to back
up 30,000 ft and know
this anxiety is your body trying to
anticipate future train wrecks and solve
them in the present so you are going
into this trying to reverse engineer
what might happen what she might feel
like challenges she might have down the
road that's going to be a recipe for
disaster what I want you both to do is
to say every 30 days we're going to
check in on this transition MH how can I
best love you right now and expect there
to be um loss there's grief I was a
doctor and now I'm sitting at home
cleaning up spit up all day long or
maybe she's free maybe she hated being a
doctor so she gets to drive that and I
want you to create Manuel a home where
it's okay for her her to be sad on some
days for her to be cheering on some days
and your question all the time is how
can I love you this week how can I love
you next week and and when she says hey
this staying at home thing is not for me
let's have that conversation then yeah
but let's don't try to predict every bad
thing and try to solve it right now cuz
you're going to create chaos and anxiety
in your house week by week month by
month year by year this is the Ramy show
we'll be right
[Music]
back
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
this is the Ramy show I'm John deloney
joined by Jade warshaw 8825 5225 let's
go out to Indianapolis and talk to
Madison what's up
Madison hello how we doing good I have a
question so I'm wondering if I should
sell my personal car and just use my
boyfriend's company car or his personal
car to pay off some of my
bet you want to sell your car to use
your boyfriend's company
car correct I don't think that that's a
good idea this doesn't end well yeah cuz
what H like this is where my mind goes
I'm going just say it what happens if
you get in an accident in your
boyfriend's company car which means the
company's paying for him to use it for
work
Transportation so I have coverage
through his work we actually work for
the same company do you have coverage on
his vehicle or you have coverage because
you just work
there like you're listed on his vehicle
correct on both of them so his personal
car and his company car I have coverage
okay so it's it's completely
kosher yes and my car essentially is
just just sitting in the driveway right
now and I I don't touch it so I don't
know if I'm losing money by it just
sitting there um I still owe on it so
I'm still making payments but I just I
don't know if it's beneficial to just
have my car sitting here and not use it
or if I should sell it I think that's
different I think that's independent
from
him I'm more nervous about
you you're going to be very
exposed okay and I know and when I say
this you're going to go not us it would
never happen no I know no I know I
understand but you I mean that's why I
wanted to ask yeah I I if you're my
sister or you're my daughter or you're
just one of my buddies who's a woman I
would tell you if he marries you great
yall make financial decisions together
and yall go in and share a car and all
that yeah if it's a
boyfriend I mean Jade and I would not
have jobs if every every well-laid plan
ended right and so you're you're selling
your car EXP exposing yourself to him
and his company which happens to be your
company too that's just a lot of you are
hitching Your Wagon to some unsecure
horses and getting dragged into the wild
right that's that just makes me nervous
what's your car worth that's sitting in
the
driveway about 9,000 9,000 is it in it
is it paid off or you have payments on
it still I have I'm still making
payments so that's my biggest thing is
I'm paying an insurance I'm making my
monthly payments and I'm not using it
and how much do you still owe on it
about 5,000 yeah I'm going to keep it
I'd pay it off yeah keep it and pay it
off how quickly can you pay it off here
so that's that's kind of the second part
of this I have some debt and I just
don't know how to approach my debt and
what's the most important thing to pay
off first okay let's figure that out
what uh list your debts for me just as
however they come to mind okay so I have
credit card which is about 3,000 okay I
have
um house so we actually have a house so
do you want me to include my mortgage uh
who's who's listed on the Lo both of you
are listed on it yes all right we'll get
to that in a minute all right um Madison
Courthouse this weekend yeah we'll deal
with that protect yourself yes okay what
else then appliances we have about 4,000
oh Lord okay keep going and then um my
car was about 5,000 and then I have
medical debt mhm and that's a big one
and I've I've paid a lot of it down and
that's about 1,500 now okay so it's only
1,500 okay yeah um and then the mortgage
just so I know uh what is it it's about
1,900 a month yeah but how much is it
the total oh total is about 200,000
200,000 okay like John said how you guys
need to get married you're playing house
just just do it and this is not like for
religious reasons this is for you to
protect yourself legally because if it
hits the fan this is going to be so
messy and so crazy that you're
protecting yourself by making sure that
this is all legally wrapped up in a
marriage um does he have any
debt he does not he does not okay so
until you get married but you're getting
married this weekend um we're going to
list these debts and and I'm I'm I'm
laughing but I'm being serious like get
yourself the certificate go online and
do the certificate and then you guys
plan a party for later and have
champagne and have it fun but for now
let's get this legal stuff locked up is
there any reason that he would not want
to do that so when we graduated college
um we sat down and we had a conversation
and it really came down to what do we
want to do first and I'll be honest we
both agreed that we would rather go with
the house first because
of cuz we wanted to live somewhere so
our landlord actually um told us about
30 days before our lease was ending that
he was no longer going to be renting and
he was selling the house so we didn't
have much time to really find a place to
live so that's when we started looking
for houses and we lived with his parents
for a few months so you solved a 30-day
uh oh with a 30-year
commitment yes and that doesn't really
that still doesn't really answer my
question my question was if you said hey
I want to get married this weekend so
we're protecting both of our butts in
this marriage is there any reason that
he would not want to do that that was my
question
I don't think so I think it's more of
just the traditional essence of Y busted
up tradition say y'all don't care about
tradition tradition tradition's gone not
those tradition you guys y guys borrowed
money on a dishwasher youall have thrown
tradition out
me but I guess what I'm trying to get at
is I want to make sure that he
understands that we're not playing house
forever and honestly legally you need to
be protected and you need to make him
understand that hey if this goes south
there is nothing that is going to um
there is no way that this is going to be
decided fairly because there's no
marriage here so if you guys break up
and you cheat on him or he cheats on you
or you just dislike each other you have
a house together and he can just up and
leave and leave you with that debt or
you can just up and leave and leave him
with that debt or he you know what I'm
saying there's so much tied up here's
what makes me scary here's what makes me
scared and I and we're we're consciously
leaning on the other side of the Seesaw
cuz you're on the happy side oh my gosh
like oh great it's awesome right we're
on the other side if something goes
sideways in your
job if something goes sideways in your
relationship you don't and you have sold
your car and you're just driving around
town in his car you don't have a home
you don't have a car you don't have a
job and here's what's important about
that you you know that risk and you and
I'm going to believe you that risk is
very very small but do you know what
doesn't know that risk profile you're
amydala the part of your brain that is
designed to keep you safe all the time
it knows one tiny misstep and you are
homeless carless unsafe without
groceries and your body would be failing
you if it let you sleep all night in
this current situation your body would
be failing you if it let you have deep
connected intimate moments with your
boyfriend because it's trying to not
die and so when we talk about like dude
go do this now your whole body
goes and if it if the thought of getting
everything lined up so that you could
feel safe if that makes you feel more
anxious and more scared then youall go
see a pre-marriage counselor tomorrow
because y'all need to deal with that
reality you see what I'm saying right
yeah and so it's it's us loving you
because we just see the other side of
this this thing going sideways and no
one plans for that by the way nobody
plans for that and I wouldn't wish that
on you for one second I want this to
work out perfectly and I want it happily
ever after and all that stuff but woo
man you're exposed exposed exposed
exposed But to answer your money
questions we've just told you how to
handle your anxiety and your relational
questions once you get married this
weekend you guys are listing the step
from smallest to largest and now you're
combining and getting after this
together right with your combined income
combined efforts your debt now becomes
his debt both of your paychecks now
become our paychecks both of your debt
becomes our debt and you guys move
through this and you process it together
if you're not going to get married if
you're like hey I don't care what you
guys say then you pay this off by
yourself and you need to look into a way
of getting one of your names off of that
mortgage all right and figure out how to
do that that because I if you're not
going to get married you don't both need
to be on this deed work two jobs three
jobs make it happen get this debt paid
off ASAP we'll be right
[Music]
back
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show Hey
listen if you are sick and tired of all
the financial just the downer financial
news and it's you're finally waking up
to the fact that nobody in Washington's
coming to save you and you listen to
this show and you've been listening to
this show and you just think gosh I wish
everybody would just pull their heads
out and start living these principles
pull their heads out of we John any
orifice any orifice they have shoved it
in
um
um and you think how do I get this out
there you don't have to spend one penny
all we need you to do is leave a festar
review click subscribe put the little
Thumbs Up Button wherever you're
consuming this please please um
subscribe to it push the buttons like it
all the things and it kicks it up into
the algorithms and it puts us in front
of hurting people who Google can't
breathe in so much debt how do I help my
wife feel better about our finances then
it kicks these videos up because you all
have taken just 10 seconds to um do this
it doesn't cost any money and it helps
out your neighbors it helps out us it
helps out you it helps out everybody the
only way this mess gets solved in this
country is from the bottom up Grassroots
homes like yours and mine deciding we're
unplugg in from the Matrix and we're
going to make different decisions so
thank you so much for your continued
support let's R to Columbia South
Carolina and talk to the powerful Haley
what's up
Haley hi K how John how are you good how
are
you I wish I could be better honestly
well what's up
um I was hoping to get some input on on
how to best address certain Financial
behaviors in my family while also
financially preparing myself for my
future at the same time okay go for it
unpack that for us right so I'm 25 I'm
set to graduate with my masters and take
board exams um to be a clinical
informaticist in the next year
congratulations I thank you um I did
have to move home due to coid and it
being my graduate year that year a lot
of job opportunities kind of fell off so
okay um I was acquired to basically get
my it took the time to get myself
financially together um moving home I
realized how awful really our finances
were um I'm kind of treated like the
family Bank okay emergency fund yes um
anytime any emergency repairs or
anything come up I'm usually the go-to
person to go and fix it m um I've
honestly contributed financially to my
family for years the earliest memory
would be 10 balancing checkbooks helping
to pay light or water choosing between
light and
water um do you still live right now I'm
really trying to get myself in a better
place as far as getting student loan PID
paid off which will be done within the
next at least three or four years
um haly Haley Haley do you still live at
home yes sir okay when are you moving
out I need a
date the target date would be January of
2025 there's no way after all board
exams are over why you got to move that
way
up yeah and you know that
right yes sir yeah can I ask you why you
why you feel feel like you need to stay
home until that point or why you felt
like like you needed to stay home until
that
point um in
2025 gosh I'm sorry I'm trying not to
cry no it's okay it's heavy this is
heavy stuff listen let let me just say
this before you answer it no 10-year-old
should be paying their parents water
bill
period and I'm sorry that you as a
10-year-old had to take that
responsibility
on and it's going to be the 25-year-old
you who's walking across the stage with
a graduate degree I'm so proud of
you it's going to take your 25-year-old
having a hard conversation maybe for the
first time and saying the gravy train
stops
here and then you're going to feel
guilty beyond all guilt and they're
going to come after you and say all the
mean things about
you and they don't get a
vote they've used you long
enough Fair
yes sir okay so when's your move out
date now would be after exams which
would be June of next year nope let's
let's let's help you fig Let's help you
move this up let's help you move it up
are you earning any money right
now yes ma'am how much are you
earning approximately 30 I'll say 36 a
year what's that per month what are you
taking home per
month taking home per month would least
be 21 to 22 okay so okay and 100 sorry
I'm I I I got you and you've got your
student loans right how much are
those I'm currently still in school okay
so they're not due great any other debt
that would hold you back no ma'am that's
it no ma'am that's it that's excellent
okay let's start doing some research
this weekend when you get off the the
call I want you looking around your area
have you done that yet to see what an
apartment would cost a one bedroom one
bathroom in in a part of town that's
safe and that would get you where you
need to go as far as school is and
everything else is up a note in the grad
school office and saying roommate
needed I have and I
honestly I I start and then I back out
because I feel start to feel guilty yes
yeah and so you've probably heard me say
this a 100 times I'm going to say it
10,000 more times before I'm done being
on the air from this point forward I
want you to choose guilt over resentment
every
time and here's why you are choosing to
avoid feeling
guilty and in the process you're coming
to hate your
family
Fair that's fair okay let's don't do
that to
them let's don't do that to them let's
choose to draw boundaries they're going
to keep us safe and keep us
whole and let's choose to separate where
it's appropriate and it's been
appropriate for you for a long long time
cuz I could almost guarantee you that
they don't have their hooks in you just
financially but it's emotionally too
right yes sir
yeah you're worth being
free and your parents got to learn how
to pay their bills
what happens if you
disappear you go get an apartment and
you're out what happens to
them um as far as I know
financially arguing holdes in various
places um there's no retirement anymore
there's I had at one point
started a college fund I did not know
that was liquidated in until just before
I was applying to college so your
parents stole from
you they well theyo I don't want to say
it like that I'm going to they stole
from you they did they stole from their
child not
okay I want you to put 60 days on the
calendar and I want you to come up with
a plan even if you have to take some
more
hours and I want you after finals this
semester I want you moving out over
Christmas if that's
possible it's possible you're worth
being free my
friend how does that
sound honestly nerve ragging um they've
probably been telling you for a long
time that not only can they not live
without you but that you're nothing
without them
right
close yeah you
are you have been doing the hard work of
changing an entire family tree not only
by yourself but in spite of all the
people hanging
on you're about to find out you are
stronger than you ever thought possible
and you've grown muscles in places that
most of us never have to cuz we don't
have that kind of trauma and the muscles
aren't to drag them along that's right I
want you to go see your your college
counselor College Counseling Center you
pay into that fee and there's some great
College counselors out there go sit down
and say I want to make a transition plan
it's time for me to get these chains off
my arms and legs and for me to fly on my
own we love you we're so grateful for
you this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people get out of debt build wealth
find jobs and purpose that they
love and grow incredible relationships
I'm John delone joined by my great
friend Jade warshaw and we are taking
your calls on just about everything
8825 5225 is 8825 5225 let's run out to
new back to New Hampshire and talk to
James what's up James how we doing man
good you good good good what's up man um
my question is should I pay off my
credit cards or should I finish repairs
in my apartment to gain in more income
your apartment to gain income it's are
you're not leaving in the apartment
you're renting it out so um I have my
house is kind of like a duplex but not
really like a duplex so I right now I
live in the house and I have two
roommates helping me pay the mortgage
okay um and then I could you know it's
going to cost me a good chunk to finish
it I it's I've been going through every
time iip open a wall I find more more
issues yeah so I'm probably going to
stop doing
that
exactly um okay so you live in this
house you've got two of your buddies
living there with you
rentree um I'm pretty much yeah I'm
pretty much rentree right now pretty
much or you are oh yeah I I am okay
so how much debt do you have uh
including the credit cards put all of it
in there tell me all of it uh just um 77
a half thousand did you say just 7 77
and a half thousand yeah okay that's it
that's like that's credit cards personal
loans and car loans okay so let's break
it down what's the personal loan person
I have two it's um just under 20 grand
okay 10,000 each um one's like eight the
other one's like 12 okay and then what
else keep going through the rest of it
um credit cards um no sorry two car
loans um one's 17 one's like 16 17,0
16,000 why do you have two cars
homie I have three um I have my truck
that I bought years ago um I use it to
do a bunch of stuff I I I drive back and
forth from umire to California for work
is that one
paid um my truck um no that's the one
that owes I owe 17 for okay is the third
car paid for or does that one have a
note as well yes oh yeah yeah it's a
2013 Prius okay the 2013 Prius is paid
for what's it
worth uh like probably what I paid for
it's 65 to
7 no chance how many miles does it have
on
it of
169,000 it's worth I bet you can get 10
for it but that's go to Kelly Blue Book
you can get 10 for it keep going through
the
steps um but the thing is with the fre
is just go through the steps keep going
through the steps I derail this that's
my bad keep going through the
steps um I
owe so we did personal loan one personal
loan two car one car two keep going
rolling down that um I owe like One
credit card is like seven another one's
um a little over two grand okay um
there's another one that's like six or
seven okay and I think it's one
that's off the top of the
head I think other one's like four so
how do you feel right now listing out
all that
debt yeah it's not great yeah um what's
the house worth this duplex
house uh if you were to sell it I think
I don't know like 335 maybe I hope and
what would it bring in
profit um I ow 213 on right now okay so
not much no okay um how old are
you uh 29 I'll be 30 in
February when did you buy this house
this
duplex
uh in December
2019 December 2019 yep uh you need to
sell this
house you're doing you're going about
everything in the wrong direction and
apparently it needs like you said every
time you open up a wall there's
something more than it needs and you
need to sell this house you need to sell
this Prius and I want you getting in an
apartment with those same two roommates
only this time they're paying part of
the the rent and I want you to get
yourself a clean slate and let's restart
this and let's knock these debts out one
by one so that you can breathe it sounds
like you here's what when I look at this
here's what I see I see a guy who wants
to be successful financially but went
about all the wrong ways to actually do
it and it's backfiring and it's causing
you to call two people that you've never
met on the radio to get
help yeah you know what I'm saying and I
want you to be successful financially
too can we both agree that maybe you
went down the wrong
path uh yeah Poss yeah well some things
yes all things which things do you think
you did right I'm just
curious which things are right for you
in this
equation
um my job and my truck probably because
I do make money with my truck and my car
okay so job is good what kind of job do
you have by the way um I work for the
government I fix um warships oh cool and
what are you earning doing
that um this year I should um hit 98
hopefully 100 good and so the 177,000
one that was your work truck
right yes okay the 16,000 one we're
selling that we don't need it so you can
sell that one and let's keep the Prius
if you if you can't use your work truck
for like everyday stuff let's flip it
and if but if you can use your work
truck for day-to-day then let's sell the
Prius and car number
two yeah yeah so that clears out quite a
bit of debt right there ready and then
after that we've got these personal
loans and we can just work through those
Bit by Bit by Bit And if you sell this
house it's not going to bring much but
whatever it brings we're going to put on
the smallest debt and we're going to pay
that one off and then whatever is left
we're going to pay the next one off and
we're going to work through this and
we're going to pay this debt off and
when it's all said and done if you do it
my way if it's when it's all said and
done you're going to have no debt you're
going to have 3 to 6 months of expenses
in cash sitting in the bank and you're
going to be investing 15% of your
$98,000 salary every single month and
you're 29 years old you're going to look
up all of this is going to be done oh
let me look at this right quick
everything is going to be done in about
12 months if you hit it and if you do
the things that I told you in a year
from now you're going to breathe and
you're going to have a clean slate and
you're going to have cash and you're
going to have Investments started and
you're going to go oh man I'm so glad
that on October you know 27th I called
John and
Jade yeah yeah um I I do have 23,000 in
the bank though all right let's use it
to pay off this debt keep a th000 aside
as a starter emergency fund and put the
other 22,000 on this debt and you're
going to go in order you're going to
knock out the 4K card tonight the 6K
card tonight the other $2,000 credit
card you're going to work through these
credit cards smallest to largest and
then you're selling those cars and when
you look up you're going to have uh 8 12
you're going to have about $27,000 and
you're going to blow through that so
quickly cuz you have a $98,000 income
and you're single and you're on
fire and now my brother you're going to
be free this is the ramsy show we'll be
right
[Music]
back
this is the ramsy show and we are coming
up on the holiday season and many of you
are
already ah tripping out a little bit
just the thought of sitting around the
Thanksgiving table with all the cousins
and the grandparents and all the screens
and all the political opinions and all
of that one cousin that can't shut up
about Co and so listen I got you I got
you questions for humans this year we
took him one step further and we got the
Thanksgiving deck we have the Christmas
deck and we have grandparents and kids
and that was a special request that we
got so often that we sat down with some
grandparents and some kids
and we're going to save your holiday
season all right so Jade I'm pulled a
few questions out of the questions for
humans Thanksgiving deck this is
designed for people to take to
Thanksgiving dinner or lunch or whatever
and avoid all the disastrous
conversations and drama all right is
that possible I'm trying I'm trying I
want to look my kids in the eye and say
hey your old man got in the ring and
tried okay hit me families all fell
apart but we gave it a shot um all right
so what is one Thanksgiving food item
that makes you gag green bean casserole
when it's made the wrong way what's that
mean the wrong way let me I'm going just
say it right now the folks who are
getting a can of green beans and putting
cream of mushroom soup on it and then
crumbling up those French onions y'all
ought to be ashamed of yourself it's so
nasty that's a he's like that's how I do
it that's how I do it my mom taught me
the right way to make green bean
casserole and I've never seen anybody
make it this way what is it you get the
green beans and you can use canned like
the French cut kind so they're like nice
and thin you saut it with onions you add
some sour cream swiss cheese into the
sauce pour it in a casserole dish then
you take cheesec crackers and don't this
is the one time you need to buy Cheez
itss from the store name brand don't
come in here with cheese flavored you
know rounds or whatever you know what
I'm saying get the real cheese it
crumble them up bake it in the oven
you'll thank me later never make that
nasty casserole again that other kind
all right look I I like my my crispy
frenches but I'm going to need that
recipe okay yes we're on it on you got
it Austin Austin does not have a a
Discerning palette that's for sure
that's for sure I see what he brings for
lunch all right so I'm going to preface
my question with this I'll eat anything
I'll eat anything like I'm a big Steve
ranella fan like the meat eater stuff
like I will eat anything I won't eat
armadillo and that like so I draw a line
there thank you for drawing the line at
armadillo AJ's like oh it's delicious
man but
also when somebody opens up a can of
canned cranberries and it keeps the
tube of the can it keeps the yeah you
can see the indentations I I can't wrap
my head around how somebody puts that
inside their body now Austin I've seen
him like rub it on his arms and his face
he's gross but listen I don't I I just
look at and think I just want to throw
up the thought of eating that I just
can't
R CR by the way yeah I was going to be
quiet but I got to defend myself I make
my cranberry Jam from scratch there you
go scratch none of this canned stuff all
right and it's so easy all right so last
question Thanksgiving question what
makes our family weird weird and what
makes our family the best when it comes
to Thanksgiving well depending on who
asks the question I might say you're the
one that makes it weird what makes our
family weird you you you um what makes
our family weird and what makes us the
best oh
boy that's a loaded question John I
can't answer it on the air uh the things
that make us great is what we endure
together and the thing that makes us
weird is that we still hang out with
each other even Al that we've endured
together excellent I will say what makes
my family weird is I'm going to answer
this as carefully as I
can we have a really um dark sense of
humor in our house and almost every time
our Thanksgiving meal ends with really
inappropriate jokes oh gosh and my mom
storming off and it's become like almost
it's become a uh it's become almost a
family tradition and then my dad I look
over in his face or in his hands and he
always says guys y'all get to go home I
got I got to deal with this and my mom
is like I just thought by now we'd
be it's every year since I was about 12
I got to hear some of these jokes
they're not great um they're not they're
I'm not proud of them but it just
evolves and um but I think that's what
makes us not the best but also I think
it's what makes us the best is there's
just no holds bar this is going to shock
you I am kind of The Quiet stable one at
that table if that tells you anything
about where it goes I'm shook it's a
it's fantastic questions for humans go
to ramseys solutions.com and rescue
yourself and your family this holiday
season Thanksgiving Christmas New Year's
and grandparents and grandkids hey this
year go visit your parents and go on a
date and hand your parents these cards
and they can deal with the little ones
this time without just handing them
digital babysitters
all right let's run out to Atlanta
Georgia and talk to Skyler what up
Skyler hey um need some advice on what
my wife and I should do with uh her
car okay what does she want to
do so what she wants to do so we figured
out that it's burning oil and that piss
rings are bad but it's still running
fine right now okay um I'm thinking that
we should sell the vehicle now while
it's still worth like six to
$8,000 and get like an equal trade or
like a $10,000 vehicle and she's
thinking because I'm a service
technician so I drive a service vehicle
most of the time so we're together in
her vehicle 95% of the time she's
thinking sell my truck and sell her car
and get a nicer car then what would you
do for for your service
vehicle well I mean the service vehicle
I would drive it for work and then
whenever we're not in work uh or
whenever I'm not at work we pretty much
F together most of the time I I don't
want to sell my personal vehicle I mean
it's paid off one baby step 3B oh so
there's three there's your car your
wife's car and your service
vehicle yes got you why doesn't
um what about option three which is
spend a couple thousand bucks and get
this thing
fixed well the piston rings are bad on
it and it's pretty
much like it's valued at about $6,000
and you pretty much just might as well
put a new engine in it and that's going
to be almost the same value my CH my
almost total so as a service technician
here's my gut response I'm going to
scrape together $10,000 for me and my
family and I'm going to walk in I'm
going to buy this car that you know is
bad mhm that part is the that that part
makes me feel
uncomfortable it feels unethical to me
that you're going to you as a guy who
can see this thing coming are like I'm
offloading this sucker right now and
some other sucker family is going to
have to deal with
it yeah no I totally agree it's it's
just uh you know we just see it coming
you know what I mean I know I see it
coming I don't know what to do I see it
coming but it feels like a
um I don't know John I feel like if he
sells it to a dealer they're going to do
whatever they have to get it to do to
get a driver ready may I mean if he
sells it to a dealer and lets him know
hey this thing's bad in here I can see
that or if he's if he's doing private
sale and you're looking up the value
with the issues then you're disclosing
hey this is going to need new engine so
we're going to sell it $4,000 instead of
10 I think as long as you're you and I
took a call earlier where
somebody
put a pretty sheen on some Foundation
issues on a house right and now this
family is stuck and they are trapped
inside this house because they can't
afford to get out and they can't afford
to stay that's right um and so I I as a
guy who doesn't know much about cars it
makes me uncomfortable it feels like one
of those not by your hand but in your
lap situations which is I hate this for
you and it
stinks and there's an ethical way out of
this and then there's a like I I guess
as long as you tell the truth yeah tell
the truth sell it put some with it and
get her another car of of equal value or
if you can afford to put a little more
cash with it yeah and that might be the
best thing to do just be honest honesty
is the best policy yeah this is the
Randy show we'll be right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
this is the ramsy show let's go out to
Houston Texas and talk to Amy what's up
Amy hi um I had a question my question
for yall is uh my husband and I are
wanting to downsize and um but my mom uh
lives with us here so we're not sure
what to do o why does she live with you
um I we we have two kids under the age
of two and initially when I got pregnant
um she retired so it kind of was like a
great um it was going to work out where
she kind of helped me out but she also
um has her own business that she's
trying to get off the ground and stuff
but um I guess if you asked us today we
don't know why we all still live
together um well it worked out when she
could offer the child care now how old
are your kids
now um they're they're still so one is
uh two and the other one is eight months
and um yeah and so she does contribute
like um she does uh help out a little
bit but um we are currently on baby step
one starting over again we when before
we had kids we were at a better spot we
were at baby step two but now we're back
down to baby step one trying to get back
to our emergency savings what
happened um just I think
um just build got higher and uh we we
live in a house we moved from an
apartment we were all in a two-bedroom
apartment and my husband and I and the
baby were in one room and my mom was in
another and then she retired and and
well she had retired before moving with
us and then she moved in and then we uh
got an offer to move into a house a
little bit under the market rate um
through a friend and um so we moved into
that house but now it seems like we're
house poor yeah for somebody else's home
just everything to keep up with um in a
home from the lawn to the gas bill your
mom's not paying your mom's not paying
anything to live with you guys well she
is paying uh to live with us and um but
she's like she's paying but it's not we
ran the numbers and if we move to like a
one bedroom to be gazelle and tense with
our kids we would really um we would be
saving almost $600 a month opposed to um
what she contributes the difference um
is really 50 bucks of us living in an
apartment being Delle Intense or her
living with us it's really not I'm going
to suggest that you guys don't move into
a one bedroom apartment with two little
kids me too okay that's um it's that's
what we would call napkin math that
works on a napkin it does not work in
reality y'all are going to go crazy yeah
in there now I know there are people
listening to the show or people who have
family members that are doing that
because they simply have to so I'm not
knocking it that is not y'all situation
that is a napkin math problem that y'all
did that would accelerate your current
situation what does your husband do for
a
living um he's a operations manager he
uh sprays for pest what does he
earn um he earns about 50 and what do
you earn a year um I'm a stay-at-home
mom and I I I do B on the side okay how
are you a stay-at-home mom when the
whole reason the grandma came to live
was so she could help with the kids well
it's not it's not that kind of help it's
kind of um like when she's around like
chemist um cuz she has her own things
kind of going on what did you do for
work before you were a stay-at-home
mom um I uh cooked a restaurant okay
I need you to go back to
work okay and in some capacity and we're
going to figure that out there's going
to be a way that you're going to work
quarter time work part-time or work
nights or work weekends but you need
money coming into the house because if
$600 a month is making or breaking and
causing you guys to think that maybe
we'll move into a one-bedroom apartment
with four of us there's other ways to
get that $600 back in your pocket and
it's called your Saturday and Sunday or
your husband's gonna spray all day and
then he's gonna go work the 8:00 P.M to
11:00 p.m shift or 8:00 P.M to midnight
shift after dinner with the kids yeah he
just interviewed to um deliver pizzas
okay good and and I've been and I bake
on the side and stuff um baking on the
side is is that's not going to bring the
money you need yeah that you can do that
while the kids are awake I'm talking
about things to do to make even more
money when your husband's home like at
night and also on the weekends or when
you're when grandma's home and by the
way if Grandma's still going to live
there this is when you cash that chiping
and you're like Grandma I need to go
work cuz we're in debt yeah we're
struggling and we're going to do one of
two things we're going to sell this
house and go to a two-bedroom apartment
and you're going to find a place we're
going to or here's the three things we
need to raise rent M um because we're
trying to find a $600 spread our husband
my husband's going to take a second job
I need to work a little bit and we're
going to have to raise the rent a little
bit on you if we're going to keep all
keep this house um or um and I'm going
to need some help from 6:00 a.m. until
10 a.m. because I got to go back to work
because I gotta get this we got to get
this debt down how much debt is it by
the way uh we have 42,000 Al together a
a car and um student loan okay how much
is a student loan and how much is the
car the student loans is 30 and the car
is 12 okay so the car is okay um student
loans 30 all right yeah that's right now
you bringing in an income changes
everything because if you've if you've
proven that you guys can live a life on
$50,000 then if you got another
income you if you if you found a way to
earn $40,000 a year it would change your
entire life and you'd be out of debt in
a year do you see how I did that yeah
and even if that means you having a hard
conversation with your mom and saying
mom I know you've got your thing on the
side we're going to have have to do one
of two things cuz the numbers aren't
working out we're going to need some
help here cuz I got to go back to work
or um we have to sell a house we're
going to move to a two-bedroom apartment
and we don't own the house we're renting
the house the house you're in right now
yeah the house we're in right now is a
house of renting how much are you paying
I got you how much are you paying per
month uh 15 currently 15 it's supposed
to go up to 1750 so that's why we're she
looking at options um she pays well we
had started decreasing her rent because
we thought she was going to leave she
said uh it was planned that she would
leave in November but um things change
So currently she pays 350 yeah that's
not
enough yeah it sounds like you yeah so
all in all the the rent is
8,850 and she's just paying 350 of
it um well the rent currently is 15 and
she pays uh she was paying 550 and then
it grad went down as she was getting
ready to exit but now it seems like I'm
not mad at that she's paying a third and
I don't think that you're going to find
I don't think I don't think you're going
to find anything cheaper than this
honestly what did you I mean did you
look at two-bedroom apartments before
you looked at one-bedroom apartments and
1, 1500 is 500 a month that's I had
that's the number I had in my head for a
two for a one-bedroom no no for this
apart for this house yeah I yeah for the
mom you're saying yeah I think that's
fair fair yeah I think that's fair my
question guess was is there a
two-bedroom I feel like when I look at
this I'm like that's a pretty good price
to rent a house that is housing all of
you if you go I don't know that you can
find anything cheaper that's you know
what I'm saying like I don't think that
you should get out get rid of this house
this rental situation the cheapest thing
I found was a one bedroom with a study
yeah that's not work hey here here's a
bigger question do you want your mom
out um be be
honest
I'm I'm an only child so it's really
hard to say that because feel guilty you
feel guilty and you love your mom just
because you wanted to move out doesn't I
love my mom to the moon and
back and I don't live with my mom right
both of those things can be true so
essentially yes because I want to live
the life of my husband and my children
of course course you do of course you do
it's time to have that
conversation hey that's not wrong or bad
not a bad thing that's so normal and so
normal that you want to live your life
in your house with just your husband and
your kid there's nothing wrong with that
girl
okay so on the financial I guess we just
you got to start working if you can find
30 and he can find another 10 you're out
of debt in one year 12 months that's a
drop in the bucket and it's going to be
awful and do it anyway it's not going to
be that bad they've been living on
50,000 as it is that's right yeah it's
choosing your heart right yeah you guys
got this you're going to have to make
some sacrifices and some real choices
but you can do
[Music]
it
today's scripture of the of the day is
Isaiah
4031 but those who hope in the Lord will
renew their strength they will soar on
wings like eagles they will run and not
grow weary they will walk and not be
faint the great Lars ol founding member
and drummer extraordinaire of Metallica
says stretching your parameters is a
necessity if you want to keep growing I
like it hey when you hear Isaiah 4031
does it make you think of Remember the
Titans always like eagles y'all like
eagles y'all remember that love that
love it love anyway all right let's go
out to Birmingham Alabama and talk to
Phillip what's up
Philip how's it going we're rocking on
to the Breaking Dawn brother what's up
all right man I just had a quick
question so uh well one thing to start
off my wife and I started uh doing the
the snowball two months ago we've
already paid off $35,000 in debt
whoa what' you sell did you sell
something
no well I'm in sales and so uh I had a
big motivator to uh make some extra
money and I had my biggest month ever
and was able to uh pay off a lot of debt
really quickly congratulations man
that's fantastic so what's up yeah all
right so um question my grandmother is
being taken advantage of financially by
my aunt a I'm wondering how I can step
in and help how have you already tried
so
I I haven't tried yet okay I haven't
said anything to anybody and the
situation I'm about to share I'm not
even supposed to know but my mom told me
because it's one of those it's like an
emergency situation so um I'll give you
give you some context so my on the on
the back end my grandmother she
struggles financially didn't invest in
retirement didn't know who bve Ramsey
was ever until I I started going into
him a while back and so unfortunately
she wasn't up now she's in her 70s has
no retirement and she just draws Social
Security and I think she brings in like
1400 a month so she's she's she's she's
okay she's not like very thin yeah very
thin yeah no margin there so she came to
me two or three years ago about um how
does
she um how does she get some breathing
room and so I I essentially bought her
house for what was owed on it and put
some money into it to fix it up and she
lives there for free she page utilities
and that was kind of a retirement thing
she and I worked out so that gave her a
little bit of margin but your name's on
your name's on the house you own it
correct okay correct so um so anyway so
she's been fine for two or three years
like not rich but she's doing good well
my my aunt who is her daughter um is uh
very bad with money very very bad with
money and almost weekly it seems like is
asking my grandmother for money nothing
big it's usually 40 bucks here 50 bucks
there but that stuff add up especially
when it's coming from somebody with no
margin um so anyways it's always
bothered me I hadn't said anything it's
my grandmother's money whatever um but
recently uh last week I got a call from
my
mom um my my grandmother ended up paying
a a bill utility bill or something for
my aunt and my aunt apparently took a
picture of her debit
card and ended up using it for other
things as well without telling my
grandmother wow yeah and last month um
my grandmother is at Walmart checking
out getting groceries and car gets
declined which is one embarrassing but
too it's a it's one of those you're like
oh my God I know I have money in there
and it's not there what's going on
that's straight up illegal yeah it's
stealing yeah yeah so she goes and
checks and uh apparently about $500 has
been spent um without permission from my
grandmother's card um on an online game
that my aunt has been
playing um and so anyways grandmother
confronts the
aunt and the aunt goes oh I don't know
how that happened you know that's crazy
I'll try to get your money back that
whole thing and that's kind of where
we're at and I'm not supposed to know
about this because my grandmother knows
how I'm gonna you know react well here's
the deal here's the deal so this is one
of those situations not by your hand but
in your
lap you didn't ask for this situation
you didn't ask for somebody in your
family to be so deceitful as to steal
from an elderly mother wow and quite
honestly quite frankly you didn't ask
for your mom to not get involved with
her mother and her sister which is her
responsibility as you started talking my
first question to you was going to be
call your mom or why haven't you called
your mom and your mom has passed the
buck to you
and so yeah I would if I'm you I would
tell my mom mom you have 24 hours to get
involved and then I'm going to get
involved you've given me this
information and I can't sleep at night
I'm the homeowner I've already bailed
this whole family out of problem one and
I'm about to go get involved again too
and by the way I'm going to call the
police I was about to say mom's going to
get her credit her her debit card
changed she needs to do that before the
day is over she did that already okay
good um but are you calling the popos
I'm call cuz that's what I'm doing I'm
calling the
police at the very minimum I'm making it
very clear to my to my aunt because
nobody else in the family
will if you come near grandmother again
and ask for money I call the police cuz
you stole
this right and I understand that this is
awkward and weird unfortunately your mom
put you in a very awkward weird
situation unfortunately your family has
not been as responsible with money as
you have been and they have put you in
multiple awkward weird positions and if
people keep doing that to me I'm going
to take the straightest path
out and by the way okay grandmother can
do what grandmother wants to do as much
as that pains me to say so if she says I
want you to butt out you are not calling
the police get away from me I don't want
that's going to hurt it's going to hurt
like called bloody hell and she gets to
do that because she's a grownup and it's
her
money yeah
right yeah why did your mom not make a
whole bunch of calls and ring all the
bells if I found out my little brother
was stealing from my mom oh it's going
down oh my gosh he would never in a
million years do that he's such a person
of high integrity why didn't your mom
get on the phone with your her sister
immediately well she she said something
to her or or sorry she wanted to say
something but my grandmother goes hey
I'm telling you this I shouldn't have
told you don't say anything to your
sister don't say anything to anybody
well don't tell my mom is exctly my mom
calls me I'm the responsible one in the
family when I speak people in the family
listen because they're like you know
like he means what he says he says what
he he means you know all that stuff good
for you for for breaking this family
curse I I I would tell my mom you've got
24 hours to get right in the middle of
this cuz I'm going to and she'll say oh
Phillip don't do that please grandmother
told me in confidence grandmother wants
someone to help or she wouldn't have
said anything yeah that's what I'm
thinking and she's thinking I told my
daughter and nobody's helping well she's
hoping there's a way this could be done
where no one's feelings get hurt and no
one has to know about it and that that
you can just sweep it under the rug but
that's you're so far like that it's just
not possible no at this point yeah yeah
I'd put everybody on notice and here's
the other thing you're sending a message
one of two messages number one if you
don't want me involved you better not
tell me because I'm getting involved
number two um I don't play this game we
treat each other with dignity and
respect we don't steal from family
members we don't steal from our elderly
mothers wow we don't we don't commit
fraud in our own house I won't stand for
that and there we go at the end of the
day all so this might even be a little
bit weirder that's your home you can
tell your aunt you are not welcome in my
home right yeah you could tell your aunt
I'll no trespass you on my property
because grandmother's a tentant tenant
of my place MH but not
welcome oh it was an accident I didn't
mean to it wasn't an accident that's not
an accident she got caught yeah she was
trying to make some money on an online
game and wouldn't you know it she didn't
win man golly hey I'm glad you I'm glad
it's you Philip because you're a person
of high integrity and High character um
just just for a moment like this hey I
want to thank all the guys in the booth
and Skyler thank you America for tuning
in and listen to the show great job Jade
hey be kind to one another pay off your
debts don't steal from your
mothers we'll see you soon right here on
the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
a